よろしくお願いします
今日は 3回目の話で テーマは運命は果たして変えられるかということなんです
で あの 明確にあのテーマはちょっとダブっちゃうんですね
あの本当はこの前の話で
まあ今日言うべきものはまあほとんど半分以上言ってしまったんです
まあそういうことで まあ明確にテーマというよりは
まあいろいろダブってしまうということはあるんです
で  2回目の話で あの この
こういうことを言ったと思います
もし録音なさっているならば
あの 一回聞いた方がよろしいと思いますし
あの 私はほとんど忘れましたけどね
2回何を言ったかということを
いくらこういうことを言ったんですね
心っていうのは何かある
生まれると何かある形
決まったような感じにあるんだと
で それはなかなか変えられないんだと
ですから 例えばいつでも失敗する人は
まあなんだかんだでも
まあ人生終わるまで何やっても失敗してしまっちゃうとかね
そういうあの あの 幸福な人はいつでも幸福になってしまっちゃうし
不幸になる人は まあ終わりまで人生はまあ次から次へと不幸なことを連続に出てくると
そういうのを我々経験で知ってるんですね
一般的に不幸という人は
まあ連続的に不幸ばっかしになっているし
で 一般の人にとってもたまたままあツイてる時あるんですね
ツイてる時はもうなんだかんだもツイてるし
ツイてない時はもう何から何まで全部悪くなってしまっちゃうということは世の中であるんですね
それはどういう心の働きかという
まあ仏教で見る科学的な立場で
心理学的な立場で この前説明してたんですね
で なぜかというと そういうものはすぐ人間っていうのはこの信仰とかね
迷信とか まあそういうものに持っていっちゃうんですね
で 例えば不幸の連続の人がいると
まあもう何だろうかとね
まあなんとかそういう迷信的ないろいろ解釈しようとしちゃうんですね
そこで仏教はそういう迷信的に解釈ではなくて
まあその人の考え方 思考パターンがもう生まれつきそうなってるんだと
だから思考パターンによって
まあ幸福を呼ぶか不幸を呼ぶかということはなるんだと
ですから そこにあるのはこの思考パターンさえ変えれば
我々の人生も変えられるんだということなんですね
そこで仏教の業で 業論で言えるのは
生まれると 生まれるというのはお腹の中から出る瞬間ではなくて
お腹に入る瞬間なんです
仏教の生まれるということは
お腹にいる時でも 我々はもう人間に生まれていると
それは仏教の立場なんですね
一般的な世界では まあお腹から出てからもう人間であって
お腹の中にいる間はもう人間じゃないんですね
仏教では違いますし お腹に生命が入ったら
その瞬間から人間なんです
形があってもなくても
最初は形も何もないし
見えないほど小さいし
それでも正真正銘の人間として見ているんです
そこで そのお腹に命が入った瞬間
その人の性格 思考パターン
どのように物事を考えて判断しているかということは
もうそこで決められるんですね
そこは信じられない方々に私は礼を申し上げましたし
いろいろ赤ちゃんを預かっている人々が結構経験ありますから
やっぱり赤ちゃんは世の中のこと何も知らないのに
生まれたその瞬間から自分の性格を持ってるんではないかと
ですから 赤ちゃんを見ると
みんなそれぞれバラバラ性格を持ってるんですね
ですから この一番理解しづらければ
もう生まれてすぐもう 1週間
2週間  1ヶ月間の赤ちゃんたちを見てください
見たらみんなやっぱり性格が違う
全く別人である それぞれ
ということはわかるはずなんですね
で ヨーロッパ的な考え方ではから言うと
やっぱり教育次第だと
教育次第でどんな人でも天才にすることはできるんだととは言ってますけど
仏教ではもう 100%それはできないんだと
教育次第で立派な人間にするということは
で いく分はできます そのできることはこの世の中で受ける知識なんですね
この世の中で受ける知識がきちんと整理して
小さい時からちゃんと頭の中に流し込めば
それなりに知識人にはなるんです
でも その人の本来の性格自体は変わらないんですね
そこである日突然性格が変わる場合もあります
例えば 小さい時からずっと大人しくいた人が突然すごい乱暴になったとか
ずいぶん乱暴な人が大人しくなったところで
大人も大人になったところで大人しくなりましたとかね
そういう場合は思考パターン変わるんじゃないかなと思うかもしれません
ちょっと明確に言います
皆様 私より皆様に経験があると思いますけど
ずっと社会で生きてるんだから
私は社会から離れていつでも一人の生活ですからね
まあほんのわずかな人間関係しかないし
でも ですから明確に言います
いろんな人がいたら 小さい時は大人しい
ある日突然すごい乱暴なものになって
もう後の人生は大変乱暴な性格になってしまったと
その場合は大人しく物事を見る思考パターンがもう二十歳になってから
あるいは三十歳になってから変わったんではないかと
世の中はもう違う目で見るようになったんではないかと
じゃあ思考パターンが変わったんではないかと思うかもしれません
で 私も知ってるんですよ
小さい時 すごい乱暴な人々がいて
どんどん大人になってきたら
まあものすごく大人しい
すごい行儀がいい人間になってしまうと
それで我々の思考パターン
思考方向性が急に突然変わるんじゃないかなとも思うかもしれません
でもそれは表だけ見ると
あ 変わったなとわかるんですが
基本的には変わらないんです
私は確かめたところで
みんな社会から随分乱暴な子供だと
もう何の見込みもない
将来性もないんだと こいつは大きくなったらもう犯罪者になるよと言われた
子供たちを観察したことがあるんですね
随分仲良くして で 観察してみると
別にその子供をやることは全部乱暴なんですけど
心はそうじゃないんですね
で ある子供に対して私が言ったのは
ものすごくもう人をいじめるんだと
動物をいじめるんだと
で 私はそのすごい小さい時
もう私のところに呼んで聞いたんですね
まず仲良くしてもらって
で なんで君はそんなに動物をいじめたりね
石を投げて怪我させたりするんですかと
そしたら たまたまそちら鳥がいて面白いんだから石を投げたんだけど
あれ かわいそうにあいつに当たったと
だから それで僕は分かったのは
別にその子は他の子供と同じく小さな鳥が座っていると石を
投げてちょっと脅かして
まあまあ飛ぶの見たいとかね
そういう子供を持っている普通な好奇心しか持ってない
わざとぶん殴ってやるぞとという気持ちはなかったんではないかと
それで大人から見れば
こいつはもう小さな鳥も放っておけない人ではないかと
怪我したんでは させたのではないかと
と もう随分勝手な判断だけなんですね
そこで私はなんでいつでもみんなと喧嘩するんですかと
例を出して あんたは何々人と何で喧嘩したんですか？って言ったら
まあその人はこういうこういうことをして
こういうこういうことをやったんだと
それで言ったら向こうも怒ってきたんだから
私も怒りましたと で ここでぶん殴っちゃった
この子は力強いんだから
向こうは殴られただけで
で 考えてみれば 別に相手に対して敵意持っていたわけじゃなくて
ただ普通の常識に考えていけないと思ったことに反対して
向こう受け入れられないし
喧嘩売っちゃったんだから
こっちも喧嘩やっただけのことなんですね
で 私は考えたら この子を守ってあげればね
立派な人間になるんだと
この社会からものすごくさんざん批判して追い出しちゃえば
もしかすると社会に対して大人になったらひどくなるかもしれません
それで私は人は何言ったっても
私はあなたのことはもう大変信頼しているんだとということを言ってあげたら
それっきりでもう随分性格をびっくりするほど変わってしまったんですね
いわゆる自分をコントロールするようになったんですね
で それで私は性格を変えたかというと変えてないんです
ただ それから人生はひどくなるかもしれませんね
社会からいじめられて
それだけ大人として守ってあげただけのことで
そこでそういう悪いといういろんな子供たちを見たところで
本来心の一番底のところは悪くはないんですね
そういう人々に道だけ開いてあげれば
立派な人間になるし でおとなしく行動する人々のことを見ると
喋ってみたらおとなしく見えるだけで心の中恐ろしいんですね
ただ 社会に攻撃できないんだから
自分やられますから おとなしくいるんですね
それで見えるのは もしこの人になんか力がついて
自分の立場が出たら もうやりたい放題やるだろうと
それで大きくなったら大変乱暴な性格をするようになっちゃう
ですから まあ私が試したところでは
性格変わったわけじゃないんです
小さい時おとなしくして
大人になったら恐ろしくなったっていうことは
別に小さい時からも思考方向性はもう決まっていたんですね
ただ実行できなかったと
まあそういうことで 我々の心の中でこの実行できなくて
場がなくて まあ実らない
いろんなものはあるんです
で そこをちゃんと条件揃えたら
揃ったらすぐそれは実ってしまっちゃう
社会の人々はそこは知らないで
まあ急にああだこうだとか言うだけなんですね
なんであの人はもうという風に言っちゃうんですね
大変みんなのために 社会のために
人間のために活動している人がいるんだと
その人だけ まあなんていうまあ正直で信頼できるんだと思ってる人がいて
後でいろんな汚職したんだ
賄賂を取ったんだと 見つかったらなんであの人そうなったんですか？とかね
原因探したりするんですね
でも私から言えば もともとその人はそういう目的の人ではなかったと
ただ 賄賂やら汚職は取れる場が出ていなかったんですね
例えば学生の時はそれできない
それですごい怒りでもうこの連中には負けてたまりませんと
みんなより偉くなれそうと思って徹底的に勉強するとか
大学に入ったっても東大に入るとか
そこでまたすごい高度なレベルで勉強してしまうとかね
弁護士になるとか そこでも社会で一番上のトップになっちゃうんですね
だから何だかんだも自分がトップになりたいという
もう人を抑えたいと踏みつけたいという気持ちはそこにあるんですね
そのために正直者だと
もうみんなのためなら命でも惜しくないよといろんなことを言うだけのパフォーマンスだけであって
そこでやがて政治家になっていくらでも取れるような状態に権力を持ったところで
何のことなく賄賂やらいろんなことをしたりするんですね
ですから ただ単に権力取ったんだから
その人を汚職したんだと
そうでなかったら本当にいい人でしたというのはあまり意味がないんです
そこで社会でこの社会システム変えなくちゃいけないとかね
お金かかる政治システム変えなくちゃいけないとか
そうしたらそういう人々はそんな悪いことをしないだろうと言ったっても
それはちゃんとした病気にちゃんとした薬ではないんですね
例えば怪我しているんだったら指で押さえておけばいいんじゃないかと
血がもう流血というんですか
血が流れてるんだったら
でも指で押さえることは答えにならないんですね
怪我しているんだったら
そこは治さなくちゃいけない
で 社会はそういう深いこのところの心の働きは見ないんですね
見ることも不可能なんですね
我々の行動から やってることから判断するしかないんです
ですから 社会では心理学もありますし
社会学もありますし 教育もありますし
現代子供たちはなんで悪くなってるんですか
だからなんとか教育システム変えなくちゃいけないとか
みんな一生懸命頑張ってるんだけど
そのどんな答えでもぴったし問題に合わないんですね
なぜぴったし合わないかというと
その表だけ見て 今の子供たちはナイフ持ってるんだと
だからそれをやめるために何とかしなくちゃいけない
それだけ見てるんですね
それだけだったら禁じられればそれで終わりますからね
ナイフ持ってくるなと
それで問題は解決しないんですね
やっぱり今の子供たちのナイフ持つ問題っていうのは
本当は最近の問題じゃないんです
私が学校に行った時も
子供たちはナイフ持っていたんです
これ 50年ですから 私今 53歳だから
まあまあ 5歳  6歳で学校に入ったんだから
だからまあ 45年前の話でも
私の教室の子供たちでもナイフ持っていたんです
ですから それは持ち物検査とかね
で そういうものでは解決しないんでしょうし
そこであの 私たちは古い時代の人間だから
今みたいなかっこいい
この何て言いますか このナイフなんかあったわけじゃないんです
全部あの鍛冶屋さんで頼んで注文して作ってもらったものなんですね
私の学校にいたこのナイフ持っていた子供が持っていたナイフというのは
それは鍛冶屋さんで注文して作ったものだから
今売っているものよりは随分性能が違うんです
ものすごいもう見るだけで怖くなるほど
ものすごく切れるんです
そこで磨けば研げば研ぐほど
もう恐ろしい武器になるんです
そこで普通ナイフだったら切れる部分は一つ面だけでしょう
そうじゃないんです 両面も切れるんです
両側もものすごくこのカミソリみたいに切れる
磨いてまた前とんがっちゃう
それは何の仕事もできない
人を刺すことしか それにまた学校に持ってきたいんだから
それなんてい ちゃんと革の袋まで作って
自分ケガするんだからね
ですから その時も僕はその子供たちと聞いたら
やっぱり僕は言ったのはあんた方は怖いでしょうと
何で持ってるんです？って言ったら
やっぱり誰かもうなんていうのかかってきたら
やっぱりもう自己防衛に持たなくちゃいけないんだと
で 聞いた途端 私はもう子供の割にすぐ頭に浮かんだのは
この連中は怖いんだと
臆病者だと 何も持ってないんだったら
誰も刺そうとはしないでしょうと
言って あなた方は怖いでしょうと言って
まああまりそういう まあ別にあれで刺そうとも思わないで自慢してるんですね
ほら 見てくださいとか
授業中でもね で 僕らも興味あるんだから見たり触ったりするんだけど
まあ立派なもので ものすごいピカピカ
日本の刀みたいにも切れること切れること
気をつけて触らないと
ですから やっぱり人間の心っていうのは
昔から今もこれからもこの心の働きっていうのはまあ決まっているパターンあるんです
だから改善するならばそこら辺改善しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから ある日突然 もう小学生の子供たちがナイフ持ってるんだっていうことは
ある日突然じゃないんです
もしかすると 皆様の小学生の時代でも武器を持っていたと思いますよ
そういうことで 人間にはやっぱり生まれると思考パターンが決めちゃう
生まれる時からも臆病者な人が
やっぱり自分を守るためにいろんなことをする
その人々は随分体のことを気になる
ですから 男の場合はものすごい筋肉で
もう小さい時でも まあどうすれば筋肉を育てるかとかね
そういうことばっかりやって
ものすごいもう私が見たこの小さい時
見た子供たち ナイフ持ってた子供たちも
私より体２倍ぐらいでっかいなんです
私はずっとすごい背が小さかったんだから
見ても同じクラスの子供かともわからないほどすごい体力あって育てられた人々なんでしたけど
僕は考えたらこれほど体力あって
なんで怖いかと 手でぶん殴られても僕らは怪我するぐらい力が強かったんだけど
やっぱり体はそういう風に大きくなったっても
心は臆病なんですね だからとにかくもう運動するは
スポーツするは いろんなことをして
体力 体力 そればっかり
それで足らなくて武器まで持ったりするし
ですから 見えるのは生まれた瞬間からも
あ やばいと怖いと 世界は怖いというこの弱さで
そういう風な思考で生まれたということなんですね
そこでベースにやばいも何でもないんだ
平気やっていう風な気持ちで生まれる人っていうのは
もう何も武器も持てないし
ベースに体力なければいけませんと思うことでもないし
合気道やら色々ね もう自分を守る武術とかね
もうベースに習おうとも思わないし
で 私はこの向こうで昔からもう空手とかね
人気あったんだけど あれ何が面白いかと
で 例えばまあいろいろなことをね
手の力でいろんなことやったりすると
私もいろいろ試して 子供の頃ね
試してみたりしたんだけど
で まあこういう風に こういう風に人を殺すことまでできるんですよとかね
だからこういう風に訓練しなくちゃいけないんだとかね
僕は何のためかと ひとぶんなくって人を殺せるぐらい力を身につけてもらって
あれ何のためなの？ただレンガ代わりに放るでしょ
レンガ放っておけ あれは大事な品物だから
もうと言いたいしね で
なんとなく意味がないと感じちゃうんですね
それはどういうことかって
私は小さい時からもう怖いということはもうないんですね
世界は怖いとか 人は怖いとかは全くない
ですから それ生まれた時できたシステムで
だから体力なくてもいいんだと
いろいろ武術なんか身につけなくてもいいんだと
誰も殴ってこないんだと
その通り誰もいまだに殴ってこなかったんですね
殴るんだったら私ほど悪口の人間いないんだから
世の中でもうもうこんな頃になってると思いますけど
やっぱりいくら悪口言ったって向こう側は殴ろうとぐらいはもう元気が出てこないんですね
向こう側は怖くなっちゃうんです
なぜかというと 私は怖くないんだから
ですから この生まれた時からやっぱり思考方向性決まってあって
それは特に母親父親はすぐ分かってほしいんですね
子供の ただ小さい時は可愛さで見えなくなっちゃうんですね
鋭くこの感情なしに人を見ると
赤ちゃん見るとどんな性格かと分かるはずなんですね
おっぱいの飲み方 泣き方
遊び方 いろんなことで性格見えるはずなんですね
で そこからこの思考方向性
何とかして変えると その人はいい人間にはなるんですね
そうでないと難しいんですね
ですから 私たちは仏教のこのカルマというのは
ある特別なエネルギーでもあるし
我々持っている命のエネルギーなんですね
ですから まあなんとなくまあ幸福か不幸か
どっちかという風に どんな人生になるかという
なんとなく命のエネルギーみたいなものを持っているし
それだけカルマではなくて
自分がどのようにそのエネルギーを使うかという
このプログラムも業なんですね
だから たくさんお金あって生まれることも業なんですけど
そのお金が 財産がどのように使うかということによって
その人の運命が決められますからね
親の財産は二十歳で全部使ってしまって
もう親と共にもう破産になる家族もいるし
で それをうまく親の財産を管理して
さらに繁栄を目指す人々もいるし
やっぱりその人の思考方向性なんですね
親の仕事は絶対やりたくないと言って
もう自分の仕事をして苦労する子供たちもいるし
そういうのは世の中でごく普通にあることで
そういうのは仏教で言っている業の世界なんですね
あまりこの理解しにくい難しいことでもないんです
そこでまた前の話のことなんですけど
この悪い考え方を持ってる人々は悪い考えてる人々人とすぐ繋げちゃうんだと
仲良くなっちゃうんだと
心っていうのはいつでも似た者同士で一緒になっちゃうんだと
それでずっと不幸な人は不幸ばっかしで
幸福な人はもうどんどん幸福な道ばっかしになってしまう
我々納得いかなくたってもしょうがないんですね
それは 例えばツイてる人はもう何があってもツイている
ツイてない人はいくら助けてももうツイてないと
そこで一般的に我々はすごくそれにもう納得いかないんですね
あの人は悪いことをしているのに
ああいう風に人をいじめているのに
全然ひどい目に遭わないんではないかと
毎日毎日成長しているばっかりではないかと
こちら私たちはそれに嫉妬したりするかもしれませんし
また あの人は誰にも悪いことをしていないのに
なんで不幸ばっかしですかと
私たちも悲しがったりする可能性もあるし
で 納得いかない 納得いかなくても
それはしょうがないことなんですね
その人の思考方向性があって
その人々と付き合ってね
同じ人と付き合って 自分の運命を決めちゃうんですね
ですから 暗い考え方を持ってる人は
暗い考え方を持ってる人と仲良くする
明るくポジティブ的な考え方を持ってる人は
当然当たり前のことで
同じ明るいポジティブ考え方を持ってる人々と付き合っちゃうし
そこでかわいそうなことに
私たちは違うものを考える人
違う価値判断がある人は気に入らないんですね
あなたの考えと違いますからね
あなたとはちょっと仲良くするのは難しいんだと
そういうことでしょう
我々の生き方っていうのは
ですから 我々職業別にグループ作っちゃうし
能力別にグループ作っちゃうし
例えば上手に歌える人が一緒に歌いましょと音痴な人を呼ばないんですね
あんたはちょっと遠慮してくださいと
ぴったり歌える人がいるんだったら
じゃあ二人でやりましょうとやっちゃうんですね
それで二人とも気持ちがいいし
で 音痴な人を捕まって一緒に歌おうと思ったら
これは全部外れますから
もう歌うふうにならないんですね
だからもうすごく迷惑なんですね
話にならない ですから
人間っていうのは常に一般的に似たものが
同じ能力 同じ才能ある人
同じ思考方向性持ってる人々は一緒になるんです
そこで同じ運命で回転してしまっちゃうんですね
それを見て 世の中がやっぱり運命っていうのは変わるもんじゃないんだと
変えられませんと 運命だから
定めだから よく一般的に言うのは
もう神様にそう決められたんだからと
それで世の中で一般常識として運命は変えるものではないんだと
だって運命だもんと ふうな考え方あるんですね
それも正しくないんですね
それは我々の心理学のこの構成を知らないんだから言ってることなんですね
私が言うのは運命は変えられますが難しいと
これは並ならぬ努力が必要ですということなんですね
例えば音痴な人がいるんだとする
その人には絶対一生歌えないかというと
そうじゃないでしょうに
その人はものすごく苦労して
その音楽知ってる能力ある人と仲良くして
ずっと生活すると なんとなく知らないうちにそれ歌えるようになるんです
私は音楽のことを全く知らない
例を例で言うんだけど
全く勉強したことも何もないし
出家者にはそれ禁じられている学問でもあるし
ですから歌えないんです
歌えないんだけど このすごいプロの人々が
生で歌ったりすると聞いてると
あれ なんか自分にもその同じ調子で歌えるんです
音の上げることを下げること
いろんなこのビブラードありますからね
何のことなく出るんですね
そこであれ 自分はれながらなんか歌えるんではないかと勘違いして
一人でやってみたらまるっきりダメ
全然声が出ない それはどういうことかというと
自分にはそういう才能
能力ないんだけど ある人につなげたら
その人の思考方向性の影響でこちらの細胞が活動する
もし私がそういう人のところに
もうお願いしてお願いして弟子入りでもしたならば
もう1年 2年でもう何のことなく歌手に歌える人になってしまっちゃう
問題ないんです 踊りの場合も同じことで
でも踊り世の中はそうじゃない
例えば音楽を教えようと学校を作っている人がすぐ面接をして歌える子供たちを選ぶんですね
音楽に才能ある子供たち
なぜならばやりやすい
居心地がいい みんな同じ気持ちの連中だからコントロールしやすい
ですから 面接でまるっきり歌う能力ない才能ない人は選ぶんだったらまたすごく違うんですね
そうするともう歌私は大嫌い
音楽は大嫌いだと じゃああなたは合格してあげますと
言って学校に入れたって
もうその子は勉強したくないでしょうに
混乱するでしょうに だから先生はまた大変なんですね
そういうことで運命変えるということは大変な仕事なんですね
大変な仕事だから なかなか人を自分の運命を変えようとしないんですね
幸福になろうとはしない
はしないんですね 不幸な人は
病気な人は病気な人のグループを作って
社会何か会を作ってそこに集まるし
がんの人々はがんの仲間としてもうなって
それでがんは治らないんですね
一生懸命考えたりはする
ということなんですね
それをずっと前の話で言ったことなんですね
そこで仏教から言えば
一切は無常 無常でないものは何一つもないんですね
一切無常と言えばちょっと間違いなんですけど
サッベーサンカーラドゥッカと言ってアニッチャーと言ってますから
現象の世界すべては無常であると
ですから 我々の心も一つの現象なんですね
この私は現象という言葉
パーリ語でサンカーラと言うんですね
で 複数だからサンカーラと言うんですね
このサンカーラっていうのは
意味は構成されているもの
できているものという意味なんですね
例えば元素というものあるんですね
化学では 元素は元々にあるもので
元素から他のものは出ているんだと言っているし
でも元素自体も核やらいろいろ電子やらいろんなものがあってできているし
核にしたってもいろんなものを組み合わせたから核が出て原子核が出ているし
そういうふうに物っていうのは
元素のような感じで独立して存在はしない
他のものを組み合わせてできているもの
例えばこちらにマイクロフォンがあるとしますね
ありまして このマイクロフォンという実体はないんです
いろんなものを組み合わせたところで
マイクロフォンだよと仮に言うんです
その働きを見て でも 一つ一つ部品が自分自分の別な働きを持ってるんですね
スタンドはスタンドの働き持っていて
カバーはカバー 自分 別な働き持っていて
いろんな部分が自分の働き持っているし
その働き全部まとめたところで我々はマイクロフォンと言うんです
だから一般的にマイクロフォンありますけどもありますと言えますけど
分解してみればマイクロフォンが消えちゃうんですね
だからどこまででも分解すればするほど消えて消えて消えて消えていっちゃうんですね
そういう風に現象というものがあるんです
世の中に 仏教ではサンカーラという言葉を言うんですね
サンカーラという言葉でそれを言ってるんですね
そこで一切の現象は無常なんですね
組み立て でできたものだから
必ず壊れるんですね 壊れないものはないんだと
支えられているものだから
で 例が悪いんだけど 例えば我々は建物は
あの 地球の上に作ったりする
で 人間の立場から見れば
地球はずっとあるもので
そこで人間作るものは建物であって
そこで何が壊れるかというと
建物が必ずしも壊れるんですね
なぜ壊れるかで 作ったものだから
地球はそのまんまで でも仏教から見れば地球もできたもので
だからずっとそのままでいるわけじゃないし
原子一個を見ても同じくいろんな部品がまとめてできているもので
だからその部品一つ二つでも抜いちゃったら
原子は原子でなくなっちゃうんです
その部品自体も 原子の部品自体もまたできているもので変化していると
そのようにもうすべてのものはこの無常であって壊れるものだという仏教の考え方があります
そこに心も同じく物質より無常であると
っていうんですね それは他の宗教と比べるとかなり大胆な発言なんですね
なぜならば 普通の世の中のどんな宗教でも
体が死んでも魂は死なないとかね
精神は死にませんというふうに宗教の世界では考えているんですね
人は死んでも まあ精霊とかいうか霊魂というか
そういうものがずっと続くんだと
じゃあ宗教を信じない方々も
体は変化するんだけど
これ俺ですよと 私ですよと
生まれた時からずっと私がいるんだというふうなことを思っているんですね
私は変わってないんだと
まあ体は変わってるんだけど
そこで一般の宗教の社会でも
宗教を信仰しない知識の社会でも
やっぱり心の働きは変化しないものだと
自我意識 自分という意識
それはずっとあるものだと
と思っているんです で
仏教でいうのはものすごい大胆な発言で
体より心の方が無常であって変化するんだと
で それはなかなか なかなか納得いかないんですけど
まあしょうがない それは事実なんですね
なぜかというと 我々が私という自我意識が生まれた時からずっと変化しているでしょうに
赤ちゃん自分という世界と
ちょっと大きくなった時
自分という世界と 我々の年になったところの自分という世界はずっと変わっているでしょうに
で 瞬間に変わっちゃうんですね
何かいいことに出会ったら
ものすごくニコニコと笑って
大変幸せだと 楽しかったんだと思って楽しさを味わっていて
すぐこの心が変わるでしょ
例えば人が自分の部屋にいて
すごい暗くて悲しくて
もう寂しくて そこでやっと外へ出て
友達いるところに行って
どこかでレストランで集めて
酒飲んでご飯食べて もう歌って
もう楽しかったと すごい楽しかったと
で 自分の部屋にまた戻ったら
またすっと暗くなっちゃうでしょうに
ですから 心っていうのはほんのわずかなことで変えちゃいますよ
例えばパーティーで真っ最中で
カラオケで歌ってる人に
あの急に今電話かけてきたんだけど
あなたの母親が死んだんだと
事故で死んだんだって
言ってみてください 何のことなくそういうふうに言えますから
あなた何々さんでしょ？じゃあそっちから電話かけてきて
あの母親事故で死にましたと
じゃあ事故で死にましたという前に
もう人のあのカラオケ歌っていた人なんですけど
もうそれで終わりでしょうに
何もできなくなっちゃうし
急に何か体の中で爆弾爆発したような感じで
いきなり変わってしまっちゃうでしょうね
ですから心変わるためにはもう時間もいりません
すごい早く心変わっちゃうんですね
そういうことで心も無常ですと言ってるんですね
我々の気持ちに喋るのはもうインチキですよ
人間っていうのは死にたくない
永遠になりたい もう体が壊れても魂は霊魂は死なないと言ったらもう気持ちはいいんだけど
その人間の気持ちに沿って喋るのはインチキですね
事実喋るのはもう科学的なんですね
本当のことを ですから
まあ認めたくないという気持ちは分かりますけど
無常なんですね なんで私はずっと無常の話言ったかというと
全ては無常だとすると
運命は変えられないと言ったら
それおかしいでしょうね
変えられますか？変えられます
可能性あるんです で なぜかというと
業というのは我々の心の思考パターン
我々がどのように物事を考えて判断して生きているかという基本的なプログラム
それは業なんですね それもできてるものだから
変えられるんです ですから
運命変えるために必要なのは
すごい合理的な 具体的な
この知恵と知識なんですね
自分を徹底的に客観的に見られる
それからすごい勇気も必要なんですね
自分自身を変えることだから
それさえあれば まあ変えられます
難しいんですけど 変えられます
私たちはずっとすぐ自分の性格の方でもう落ち着いてしまうんですね
自分の性格の方で落ち着いてしまっちゃったら
その人で自分の運命変えることはできません
例えば ものすごく怠けの性格の人がいるんだと
その怠けの性格ある人はどうしても成功はしないんですね
だから不幸になる その怠けの性格っていうのは
別にやる気がないというかね
まあ後でやりますという気持ちなんですね
で ものに面白くないとかね
ワクワクしないとか そういう風な性格になっちゃうと
まあどうせ人生は不幸になってしまう
で もともとそういう風にもう怠けみたいな性格でできたならば
当たり前で人生不幸 その人が自分の性格をちゃんと見て
あ なるほど 私はどんなものにあまり興味を持たないんだと
ものをやり やり やる気っていうのは私にはないんだと
いつでもまあ後にしましょうと
風な気持ちになってるんだと
そうすると自分を見るでしょうに
自分にしかできない ほとんどそういうことも
それで見たところで じゃあ私はこれ
変えてみたらどうですか？と
やるべきことをすぐその場でやってしまえばどうですか？と
もうちょっと行動的になってみればどうですか？と
そこら辺に興味があるようにすればどうですか？と言って
苦労してでも泣きながらでも行動的になると
すぐ仕事をやってみると
後回しにしないようにすると
寝たくて寝たくてしょうがなくても
氷の水にでも入ってでも仕事をやりましょうと
ってやれば その人にはいくらか人生変えちゃうんですね
私は大学の学生の時は
なかなか勉強できる才能ない学生の方々
結構いたんです いたんだけど
その人々はもうすごくこのみんなと一緒にいるんだから
負けては 負け 負けるのは恥ずかしいでしょうし
ですから負けたくないということで
必死になって勉強する
勉強できる連中はもうほとんど遊びっぱなしで
その人々はもう遊ぶことにも行かないで
もう勉強するは勉強する
部屋になんかに行ったら
もう部屋 壁なんかないんです
全部メモを書いて書いて貼って貼って貼って
どこを見ても勉強して覚えていかなくちゃいけないものばっかりとかね
あって それで夜になってくるとどうせ眠くなるんだから
それでもう冷たい水持ってきて
バケツ持ってきて それに足を入れたりして
で もう 15 分ごとに顔を洗ったりとかね
いろいろ苦労しながら体壊しながら勉強して
結局合格するんです まあ私は勉強できないんだから
寝るぞと思っちゃったら合格できないでしょうね
だからそこでまあ自分の人生から見たら見えたのは
やっぱりものすごくこの生まれつき勉強に勉強できるような性格ができてない
それでもそういうことになってしまったんだから
必死になって苦労してなんとか合格すると
ですから 運命っていうのは
まあすごく努力すると変えられるものなんですね
うん で それからこの いくらかこの仏教の話に
一般的な話から仏教の話に入りたいと思ってますけど
で お釈迦様はこの定め
運命という言葉には反対したんですね
で 人間生まれつき全て決めてるんだという言葉
僕は私も同じこと言ってるんだけど
全ては決めてるんだと言うなと
そう言ったら 人間にはどうすることもできなくなるんだと
業は認めているにも関わらず強烈に反対するんですね
業は過去でやったことだから
いわゆる過去の結果で現在の心のシステムができ
形成されるんだったら
もうどうしようもないのではないかという
この これ専門用語いろいろありますけど
ちょっと言葉はすごく長いし
まあで 私も怠け者だから長い用語なんか書きたくない
で まあそれでも書こうとすれば書けますけど
もう長いことは長い 皆さんも大変ですけど
長いでしょう 結構 それは一つの言葉なんです
これはいいなんですね
読み方は簡単 プッベーカタヘートゥーワーダ
で 日本語で何と言うかわかりませんだけど
こういうのは言葉を集めて仏教用語を作ってるんですね
プッベーという言葉 カタという言葉
ヘートゥという言葉と
ワーダという言葉 で プッベーっていうのは過去
前という意味なんですね
カタっていうのは行ったという意味で
過去であったことという意味なんですね
ヘトっていうのは原因
ワードっていうのは論
原因でもいいし因でもいいし
ですから これは人間の生命について説明すると
過去で行った原因によるものだという教えなんですね
ですから 適当な日本語を言う言葉がなかなか難しいんです
で 生命 人間であろうが誰であろうが
今できているのは過去で過去の行為の結果だよと
それで過去はもう終わったんだから
もう原因はもうどうしようもないんです
結果を受けるしか方法ないんだと
ということなんです 私は石を投げてガラスを割ったならば
もう石を投げて行ったんだから
もうガラスを割れたんだから
もうどうしようもないんです
また元に戻らない ですから
今私という結果が過去の原因だよと言っちゃうと
私というものにはどうすることもできなくなる
そういう論が 哲学思想体系がインドにあったんです
そういう考え方に仏教はものすごく邪見だと
恐ろしい考え方だと批判するんです
これは仏教の意見じゃないんです
で なぜそれを否定するんですかというと
全ては構成されているものだから
いわゆる因果法則 常に今も私は構成されてできているものだから
それから物事は変化しているんだから
原因変えれば条件変えれば変わるでしょうし
絶対的に変えないということはないんだと
ですから因果法則にこれ反対するんだと
この考え方 それから全ては過去の結果だよとおっしゃったならば
人々は努力しなくてもいいことになっちゃうんですね
悪い人は悪者でいいんだと
善人が善人でいいんだと
しょうがないんだと もうどうしようもないんだと
という風になっちゃうんですね
ですから これは恐ろしい考え方だと
たとえ犯罪人であろうとも
もう何とかして改善できるんだと
というのは仏教の立場なんですね
それは仏教因果法則の教えから言っていることで
[咳]ですから これだけ覚えておいてください
我々の運命というのは努力すれば変わるものだと
全ては無常ですよということで
変わる可能性 見込みは見えるんです
変化するんだから いい方向へ変化させさせればいいのです
ですから 無常論というのは決して暗い考え方ではないんです
単なる事実だけです で
無常だから何でも可能なんですね
無常でないと何もできなくなっちゃうんです
変化しないものだったら
ですから 無常ということで
何でも人間に可能性が限りなく出てくる
じゃあこれから仏教でこの何が不幸になるか
何が幸福になるか それ前にも言ったと思いますけどね
そこら辺ちゃんと説明しているんですね
で 人間っていうのは あの
我々にいつでもこの心に何となく分かっていると思いますけど
いつでもなんとか何かエネルギーがあるんですね
そのエネルギーに専門用語なんですけど
パーリ語でチェータナと言うんですね
チェータナ このパーリ語を書く場合はいつでもチャと発音するんです
このチェータナというのは日本で言えば意思なんですね
日本語で言えば意思 人の意思
何でした で 意思と言ったらもっと大きくて大きいことになっちゃいますけど
いつでも我々の心の中で何かしたいという気持ちがあってするんですね
心見ればわかるんです
わからない方々は 例えばお腹が空いたらどうなるんですか？すごくエネルギーが生まれるので食べたいということは
眠くなったら寝たいという意思が生まれてくるんですね
お腹が空いたら食べたいと
寒くなったらなんとか暖かくしようという意思が生まれちゃうんですね
そこで意思がないと 人間というのは何の行動もしないんです
もっと厳密に考えちゃうと
例えば食べたいという気持ちがあると食べる
食べたくない だから食べるという人はいませんし
全く眠気がなくて眠たくない
だから寝るぞという人はいませんし
だから人間というのは
自分はやることはやりたいんだからやってるんです
それは大きなことわかりますから
細かく見てください 細かく見ると
我々はまぶた閉じる時でもまぶたを閉じたいんだから閉じているんです
喋っている私もこの手を動かしているんですね
その手を動かしたいんだからそうやってるんです
ただ気づいてないだけ
あ それはまあ単なる連鎖反応
何反応って言うんですか
あれは リフレックスアクション
なんて言いますか 反射
で 反射的な反応で手を動かしているんだよということではないんです
心の働きはすごいきめ細かいんだから
ただ気づかないんですね
お腹が空いたら食べたいということは
もうあまりでっかい体験だからわかりますけど
ですから このまぶたを閉じる時でも
まぶたを閉じたいという意思があってまぶたを閉じる
そこで皆様は気づいてないんだけど
呼吸してるでしょ あれも意思があって呼吸しているんです
ですから 心のこの小さなところの働きまで捕まるために
瞑想という精神的な訓練を教えてるんですね
じっと集中して自分の心の呼吸を見ていると
自分にこのお腹が空いたいという気持ちと吐いたいという気持ちが生まれることが見えてくるんですね
その気持ちさえ消えちゃったらもう呼吸もしないんです
だから意志が消えちゃったらそこで人が死んじゃうんですね
でも意志っていうのは消えるものじゃないんです
いつでもあるんです だから死ぬ心配はないんです
死んでも生まれちゃうんです
簡単ですから なぜかというと
死にたいという人がいるんですか？いないんです
自殺する人も死にたくないんだから自殺するんです
その 僕らみたいな頭の悪い人々から見れば大馬鹿もんなんですけど
その人々はエリートたちだからね
すごいかっこいいことをやっていると思ってるんですね
必死になってもうみんなコントロールして管理して生きていきたいと思っていて
それができなくなっちゃったら
もう腹が立って じゃあ死んでやるぞと
それで我々は何か痛い目に遭うと思ってるんで
全然痛い目に遭ってないんです
死んだ人はただ自分でざまあ見るだけなんですからね
誰も悲しむこにならないし
で 例えば社会のせいで
マスコミのせいで その人はもう自殺しましたと怒ったってもね
その人々はさらに怒ってるだけで
誰もあまり気にしないし
まあとにかく死ぬ時でも死にたいという気持ちはないし
ですから まあ死んでもすぐに意志が行動して心が繋げちゃう
それで呼吸なんか見てみると
例えばこの瞑想をなさっている方々は
ものすごく深く深く瞑想してみると
自分で吸う 吸ったらもう嫌になる
これであかんと だから吐かなくちゃいけないんです
それで吐いちゃうんですね
吐いたところで結果はそれまた気持ち悪いんです
吐いてみたら あ これではあきませんと
いけませんと じゃあ吸わなくちゃいけないんだと
それで吸う 吸ったらまた嫌なんですね
その状態が それではこれで行けませんということで
また吐くと そういうことで全然終わらないんですよ
この吸ったり吐いたりすること
で 瞑想しない方々は一人もその経験ないんです
吸うのは苦しい経験だと
吐くことも苦しいんだと
とことんとことん集中して
体をリラックスして 他の痛みも苦しみも全部もう排除して
心を落ち着いてもらって
清らかな心で これだけ丁寧に鋭い知恵で見ていると
あ 吸うことも嫌なものだと
だから吐かなくちゃいけないことになるんですね
吐いたら吐いたことは嫌な気持ちですと
それで吸わなくちゃいけないことになるんです
それは どういうことかというと
まあどんな結果があっても
その結果はあまり好ましくないんです
ですから じゃあ次のことをしようとなるんです
そういうことで 物事にもうなかなか終わりがなくなっちゃうんです
他の例で言いやすいんだけど
この呼吸ほど分かりやすくはないんです
例えばお腹が空いたら
やっぱりそれいけませんでしょうね
いかないでしょうね なんかその気持ちいい気持ちじゃないんです
あ これは嫌だと それで食べろという気持ちが生まれる
意志が生まれる それで食べる
食べるところでその気持ちまた良くないんですね
じゃあやめましょう で
やめちゃう お腹にもの入っちゃったら
胃がもう嫌なんですね
それで何とかしてそれをもう出さなくちゃいけないんですね
で 全部消化して出したりする
出しちゃったらまたお腹が空いちゃうんです
胃も品物入ったら嫌だ
嫌だなと思ったら 空っぽになったら気持ちいい
せいせいしましたと 思っちゃえば
もう二度と人間食べないんです
あ お腹空っぽになってもうせいせいしましたと言わないんですよ
何もないんだからこれはあきませんと
それでまた信号が出てきて
脳細胞に もう空腹を作っちゃうんです
終わりがないんです その食べたものは消化して
どんどんどんどん大腸の方に行ったらどんな気持ちですか？気持ちいいですか？すごい気持ち悪いでしょうね
それでそれを排出しなくちゃいけないでしょうし
それで もういつでも人間が気持ち悪いという感じで生きてるんです
だからもう次のことをしようと
それまた気持ち悪い じゃあだから次のことをしようと
そういう風に続けていっちゃうんです
ですから もう意志という働きが限りなくあるんです
消えないんです 消えることは不可能なんです
それまた同じ意志じゃない
いろんな意志 食べたいと意志と
食べることをやめたいと意志と
違いますからね 寝たいと意志と
起きたいと意志が違いますからね
意志も無常ですけどね
無常でそこにあるんです
なんで意志 チェータナのことを言ったんですかというと
このチェータナ自体が我々の業なんですね
チェータナイコールカルマなんですね
カルマは業ですからね
そこで あの あ 業なんか仏教で言ってる業なんかもう全然わからないと言っても
それ理解しておけばそれは業なんです
意志あるでしょうに ずーっと
だから生まれる時 意志が強い人はそれなりに強く行動する
弱い人は弱く行動するっていうこともあるんです
ですから 例えば人に自信があるっていうことはどういうことですか？意志が強いってことでしょう
自信があったらもう成功するでしょうに
例えばオリンピックのようなところで
みんな同じ才能を持っていて
それでちゃんと体の訓練はちゃんとやっていて
それでわずかでも他の人々がやばいと思っちゃったら
わずかでも負けちゃうんです
見てください オリンピックでメダル取る人々はみんなちゃんと上手だから勝ったんじゃなくて
なんかどこかでなんか運命で勝ってるんじゃないんですか？見たらすぐわかる
この人は勝つ この人は負けると
この人こけると 見てすぐ見えるでしょう
私はもう出たらこの人はかわいそうやと
で 経歴やら履歴見たらものすごい上手なんです
いろいろなことは これは訓練していました
これも訓練していましたと
今日初めてこれはオリンピックで自分でチャレンジするつもりですよとか言ってるんだけど
そのになっちゃうと なんかどこかで自信がなくなっちゃって
もうこけてしまうっちゃうですね
で 完璧に自分の分の競争でやる人々は
何かどこかで別にもう人のことも気にしない
自分のことも気にしないし
ただそのやることだけに集中して
それやって終わって勝ったかと後で気がつくぐらいなんです
だからなんとなく あのー
不可思議にそのカルマが働いてるんです
その場合は こういうあるプロがテレビで言ったんだけど
あのまあ「日本も大丈夫でしょう」とか言ったら 「
いえいえ いくら訓練したって大丈夫といえません」と 「
それは見ると それはもう
もう運命ですよ」と 言ったら
あのもう人がなんか こんなもうちゃんとした科学的なスポーツマンが
このコーチが「なんで運命と言うんですか」と
やっぱりその人々わかってるんです
いくら訓練したっても
いくら記録あっても その場でどうかわからないんだと
ですから そういうこと
別に今日の話に何の関係もないんだけど
やっぱり人の意志っていうのは人の業であって
それによって成功するかしないかっていうことはもう決めちゃう
意志もたまに強くなったり
たまに弱くなったりする
外の影響を受けちゃうんです
例えばボクシングについてすごい自信がある人が
もう もうこの人は あの何て言いますか
この 「チャンピオンになるぞ」と
思ってても だから試合に出たところで試合
その人見たところで 「
あれ この人なんかすごい強そうだな」と思っちゃったら
その瞬間どうなるんですか？負けちゃうんですね
あの昔の あのボクシングのチャンピオンがいたんですね
あのキャシウス・クレイという人で
モハメド・アリとムスリム
イスラム教になった人
この悪口 なんかインタビューしたらものすごい汚い言葉散々言うでしょうに
相 試合相手を貶すこと貶すこと
だから悪口言うにはその人有名でしたからね
だから彼が言うこともう世界中広がるでしょうね
もう世界的に人気あったし
あれは何かというと 別にあのモハメド・アリは別に人に対して怒りやら人をバカにする気持ちあったわけじゃなくて
やっぱり試合相手を完全にバカにしておいた方が自分が勝つんです
ただ彼の 何て言いますか
試合の一つの技だけなんですね
あんなもう口がうまくないんだから
他の人々は [笑い]だからもう何も言えないんです
ああいう風にバカにされちゃったら
腹が立つだけ 腹が立っちゃったらそれで負けちゃうし
そこでもしかすると この試合の中でモハメド・アリなんかその人 「
なんだこのもう鴨じゃないか
もう鶏みたいなチキンみたいな感じで
こいつはもう私の相手にならないのではないか」と自分に言い聞かせていたかもしれませんしね
そうすると 相手がいくら強くたっても
もう聞かないそんなことは
もう自分でもうやっつけてしまっちゃうと
ということで 意志っていうのは生まれつきもあることはあるんだけど
その時のその時の状況によっても変わっちゃうんですね
それで幸福になりたい人はどうすればいいんですか？常に強い意志を持てばいいんです
[背景音楽]チェータナーをすごく強くしておけばよろしいということなんですね
やりきれないなという気持ちあったらできない
やれません なんでできないかと自分に聞けばそれだけのことなんです
あ これ難しいとすぐ思っちゃう人はもう負けなんですね
なんでできない？できないはずないだろうと
気持ちで その気持ちで物事にチャレンジすると
アタックするとかなりの成功はします
それは運命変える一つの方法なんですね
それからさらに仏教の話に入ります
意志は 2種類あるんです
アクサラチェータナーと
もう一つはこのクサラチェータナー
2種類あるんです で あの
これは日本語に訳する前に意味を考えてください
まずクサラっていうのは
あの匠という上手という意味なんですね
アクティブ よくもう上手な人
何でもやる人という まあ匠な匠という意味なんですけど
結局は だからこちらは下手って意味なんですね
これは否定形だから で
普通の仏教 日本語の仏教は
これは一番前は不善と
こちらは善と訳しているんですね
善不善 不善と善と でも善というのは良いという意味ですからね
まああまり気持ちが通じるかどうかわからないんですね
で その善不善で理解しないで
あの なんか匠という意味で理解した方がいいんです
上手と下手という一般的な言葉で理解した方がいいと思います
で そこをよく覚えておいて
意志をこの匠な意志持つか下手な意志を持つかと
それによってもう決まれますでしょ
で そこであくさらチェータナの場合は意志は汚れてるんです
何に汚れてるんですかというと
むさぼりと怒りと無知なんですね
無知はそのうちじゃないですか
無知ですかね じゃあ知だけ書けば
で 簡単に我々はとんしんちという貪瞋痴と言うんですけどね
その貪瞋痴に呼ばれたら
それはもう下手な人 で
上手な人っていうのはそちらの反対の不貪不瞋不痴と
不入れちゃえば まあ反対側の方がわかるんですね
で まあかなり複雑なもうまあとにかく業は科学的に説明すると言ったんだから
まあしょうがない 初めからもう難しくなるんですけど
で 単なる一般の世界で言うのは意志を強く持てと
そうすると大丈夫だと
我々はそうは言わないんです
仏教では 基本的には言ってることはもう合ってますけどね
意思さえ強ければものはうまくいくんだけど
その意思が汚れてるんだったら悪い結果になっちゃうし
結果はやるんだけど 結果が悪い
意思さえ汚れてないならば
清らかであるならば いい結果になるんです
そこら辺の理解は難しいと思います
じゃあ一つ一つ説明に行きますが
あの むさぼりで心は汚れるということ
むさぼりっていうのは
あまりも自己中心に自分のことしか考えてないことなんですね
分かりやすく言えば 自分が金持ち
金持ちになりたいと 知識人に私が知識人になりたい
誰よりも頭の人になりたいと
で そこに何か自分中心に自分が何かやることしか考えてないんですね
そこで精神がちょっとガタガタになっちゃうんです
自分が得するものだから
すごく不安が生まれてくるんです
で 例として悪いんですけど
どこかのフランスかな
あの ちょっと試験があって
このまあ芸術の試験でしたけど
このバレエをバレエを習う高いいい奨学金もらうんですね
合格したら で すごい 수준高くてね
テストも で それから結構上手なね
若い人々いたんだけども
何人かがやっぱりその金目当てにいい奨学金もらっちゃうし
外国旅行できるし 外国生活できるし
それは大変ですからね
そこを狙ってるんですね
これ この試験さえ合格すれば
もうそれ将来はもう大変
もう楽々に贅沢できるんだと
それで訓練をして試験を受けちゃうんですね
ですから 踊り自体は別に悪い
知らない もう上手じゃないわけじゃないんです
そこで僕はそのテストをテレビで見ていたんだけど
その人々やっぱりあの合格しなかったんですね
その人々が でしなかっただけじゃなくて
それのその人がすごく怒って
私の時間も全部無駄に使ったんだと
そんなインチキ人々はね
育てる必要ないんだ すごく怒ってたんですね
そこで別にあのただ技術面だけ見てね
才能ある人を育てますよと思ったならば
心はどうでもいいんです
別に金持ちたくなりたろうが何だろうがそれ関係ないんだけど
やっぱりそこはあの人に響いちゃったんですね
そこで私が思ったのは
その女の子がまあ踊りは一応訓練を受けてるんだから踊れますが
それでそのグループがいろんな外国を旅行したり
もうイギリスのいい学校に入って
もうすごい それで有名になって幸福
幸福になろうではないかと
まあ幸福というのはかっこいい言葉ですけど
まあよく金持ちに豊かになろうではないかというむさぼりで自分の心が汚れちゃったんですね
ですから美しく美しくなかったんです
試験で踊った分は それでもあまりも技知ってるんだから
一応それは合格して 面接にまた行ってもらって話しちゃうと
その人がカンカン怒ってしまったんですね
その偉い人が で まあそれで失格になって
もうそういう だからまあそういう見ると
やっぱりむさぼりで汚れたら結果が悪いんです
なかなか難しい 例えば会社で成功しますと言ったら
成功するのは別に悪いことじゃないんです
でも 会社で成功するぞと思ったら
その気持ち自体がむさぼりで汚れちゃうんですね
課長になるぞとかね 部長になりますよとかね
もしむさぼりで汚れてなかったならば成功するんです
だからむさぼりが入ったら
その人は自分中心なんですね
自分のことを考えてるんです
私がということがそこにあるんです
そうするとすごく不安なんです
例えば この講義の場合でも
私がしっかり喋ってやるぞと思ったら
私が皆様を相手にして喋らなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると私の精神が不安になっちゃうんです
どういう人々かわからないし
どんな教育受けてる方々かわからないし
社会でどんな立場の人がわからないし
一人一人私の相手になっちゃうんですね
戦いの で 喋れなくなっちゃうんです
この私がやるぞと思ったら意志はあるんだけど
むさぼりで汚れてるんです
欲で汚れてるんです 次の汚れは怒りなんですね
怒りの場合も 自分というよりは相手を敵に回しちゃうんですね
やってやるぞと あんた方に何か負けてたまりますかと
そこで意志は強いんです
意志は強いんだけど 結果が悪くなっちゃうんです
このずっと今日言っていたんだけど
この自殺する有名な人々もだいたい怒りなんですね
怒りで頑張って偉くなって
それでもやっつけるぞということでやっつけられなかった瞬間で
もう自分自身も壊してしまう
ですから 総合的な結果を見ると
その方の人生はどうですかというと
結局ダメでしたと 結果でしょうに
いい大学出たんだから素晴らしかったとか
全部もう無効になっちゃうでしょ
最後の結果で ですから
この過程で一時期偉くなった
すごいいい大学出た もう弁護士になった
専門家になったとか いろいろもう政治家にもなったとか言ってますけど
そこだけ見るとすごいと思うかもしれませんだけど
ずっと怒りで戦ってきたんだから
最終的には全部ダメになって
トータル的に計算してあげると
あれは全部無効になっちゃうんです
まあ結局はダメでしたと
結局は何も何もなくなったと
ですから 結果が悪いでしょ
結局は ですから 怒りで汚れると
その瞬間瞬間合格するように見えます
最終的にはダメなんですね
チャレンジするぞと 怒りではもう相手をもう叩きというか
相手を敵に回しちゃって
もう相手に対して 社会に対してもうチャレンジする
スポーツの世界でも やっぱり昔のね
まあどんな国でもどんな世界でもありますけど
皆様は日本のことをよく知ってますから言いますけど
例えばもうヨーロッパになんかに負けてたまるかと思っちゃうと
そこで怒りが活動しちゃうと
ある部分でうまくいくかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりやがてもう全部ダメになってしまっちゃう
こちらで力全部なくなってしまっちゃうんですね
もうチャレンジできなくなっちゃうし
スポーツの場合でも あんな国には負けませんよとかね
と思っちゃったら そこで出てくるのは怒りなんですね
だからすごい微妙なんですが
自分が強く意志を持つべきなんですけど
もう怒りのエネルギーで汚れちゃったら結果が悪い結果が出るんだけど
結果が好ましくない で
3番目のエネルギーっていうのは
知と書いて無知ですね
無知のエネルギーはすごくわかりにくいんです
たまに見えるでしょうね
もう何も怖いものを知らなくて
何でも始まると で じゃあやりましょうと
じゃあ何か新しい商売でも始まりましょうかと
まあやりましょう ただそれだけで
それでもうそれだけじゃなくて
じゃあそれでお金も投資して
もうなんとか始まるんだけど
これはどのようにそれがいいかどのように
もう何もない たまにあるんですね
すごい儲かる話ありますよと
これ こういうこういうなんとか買えば
この保険買えば この証券買えば
もうもう 1ヶ月間でもう 1億円は儲かります
言ったらせっかく自分がもう用意してた
もう貯めたりとお金をもうあげちゃうと
あげたところ誰にあげたかもわからなくなっちゃって
その名刺は持ってるんだけど
探してみたら その人はそういう人はいませんとかになったりして
お金がなくなったとかね
そういうお金の金銭トラブルとか
まあ今はなかなか聞こえませんんだけど
ちょっと前いっぱいあったんですね
その時はいろんなたくさん大金なくなった方々が
ほとんど普通に社会の経験ない普通のおばあちゃんたちとかね
奥さんたちなんですね
もう獲物になったのは
そこで無知が働いちゃったんですね
無知と欲も働いたんだけど
別に自分で何とかして苦労して貯金したお金だから
まあそれはそれでいいやと思っていたと思いますよ
でもワサワサと来て  1 1で証券の話やら経済の話や
なんとか人がこうこうやってこれぐらい儲かったなと言っちゃうと
さっぱりわからないんですね
それだったらあんた信頼しますから
じゃあ持っていってくださいと
判子まで全部貯金通帳と判子をあげちゃうんです
そこで無知が働いてるんですね
別に証券に投資するのは悪いことじゃないんだけど
無知が働いちゃったら全部なくなってしまっちゃうんですね
そういう風な例を見て考えてください
我々はもう行動 無知でも行動できるんです
その人は怖いことは知らない
世間知らずと だからやるんだと
で うまくいかないでしょうしね
やればできるんだと思ってやったっても
無知でやっちゃえばダメなんです
やればできるんだ だから私はやると
そういうと無知なんですね
やればできるんだと言ったって
もうあんたよくわかってるんですかと
例えばマラソンに参加するんだと
それはやればできますよと思って参加したってもダメなんですね
やればできるんだということはいいんだけど
それからそれなりの訓練を受けて
訓練して 練習して 自分のスタミナ
体力 ちゃんと計算してから
やっぱりこの体力ではね
このスタミナではもうマラソンは無理だとと理解した方がいいのに
ただやれできるんだからねって出たってもうまくいかない
で 途中でやめるしかないんですね
ですから 無知も働いちゃうと意志に意志は強い
無知な人は バカは何でもやるんだからね
もう何も怖いものないんだから
でも一つも成功しないんですね
それでたまに成功しますよ
それはその人のおかげじゃなくて
周りの人々があまりを見ていられないんですね
そこで参加して もう全部やってあげる
その人はおだててあげて
リーダーとして いつも私の頭に浮かぶのは
自分の国の前の大統領なんです
もう死んじゃったんだけど
で 教育受けてないんです
もう全部あの全部ごまかしちゃったんです
後で学校に行って ちゃんと卒業したように全部書いてもらって
で 普通頑張り屋なんですけどね
昔からもう頑張ってもいろいろ大臣とかになっていて
それやりたくないんですね
やっぱり何とかの大臣になったら
かなり知識やら能力必要なんですね
とにかく大統領にならなくちゃいけないんだと
その人言ったことは なんでそんなに大統領になりたいと聞いたのは
もう大統領になったら全部命令するだけですよと
だから自分がバカだから
大統領にものすごい自分の国ですごい独裁的なすごい権限を持ってるんです
ですから もう自分であれやれ
これやれと言うだけで
みんな専門家が集めてやってくれると思ってるんですね
そこでもう国はもう散々ひどい目に遭いましたし
もうものすごい もうもうなんだかむちゃくちゃ
自分の誕生日はお祭りするの
1ヶ月間 それでお祭りばっかりやって人をごまかしちゃってね
国民もものすごい大バカ者しか集まってないんだから
自分も生まれた国っていうのはみんなワイワイやってるんです
私一人だけ文句言ってるんです
で どういうことかというと
私はいろんな人に話を聞くんですね
いろんなもういろんなミニストリーですか
いろんな大臣省あるんだから
まあ自分一緒に勉強した連中はみんな今すごい偉いところで仕事しているし
ですから まあ知ってるし
僕ははっきりあの人々に聞いたら
あんた方はね もうこういうこういうことやってるでしょ
どれぐらいお金かかるかと
今お金あるんですかと
あなた方にと言ったらお金あるわけないんだと
大統領命令だから いろんなこの開発やら
この国のデベロップメントですか
そういうものに用意しているお金を全部取って
大統領命令しちゃったんだから
これ法律違反なんです
命令破ったら取って大統領の誕生日に祭りするんです
だからもう悲惨な状態で
で かなり人も殺しちゃったしね
もう散々 もう人は殺すはもうもう
まあそれでも一応年近くは大統領でいたんだけどね
自分も殺されるということはあって
もうもうなかなか近寄れないんですね
その人に で いろんな人を暗殺しちゃうし
殺しちゃうし もうキリがなかったんです
ちょっとでも大統領について何か一言葉でも言ったら
次の日その人いないんです
で もうマスコミ関係はものすごくビビっていて
もうちょっとでも一言葉書いたら
その書いた人が消えちゃうんです
そういう恐ろしい時期もあって
そこでこの人を殺されちゃったんですね
どのように殺されたかというと
その人はもうある 殺し屋とすごい仲良くしていたんです
その人に個人的な人を消したい場合は
その人に頼んだりする
それでなんとかその人言ったことはやらなかったんですね
大統領が あるいはなんとか裏で何かあって
この人を怒ったんです
怒ってもそれは言わない
まあ殺し屋だから別に
もう普通なことだからね
そこでこの命令という
5月1日 労働者のあれあるでしょ
そのパレードあって そこで徹底した警備の中で大統領もパレードに行ってるんですね
でも 1KM ぐらいでも大統領知らない
顔を知らない人には近寄らないんです
そこでこの人はもう何のことなく警備をくぐってそこに行ったんです
みんな知ってるんだから
大統領の人いたのはどうですかと
じゃあ一緒にこっち来てくださいと自分そばに呼んだんですね
呼んだのは呼んだんだけど
それでボーンと爆弾で粉々になっちゃったんですね
そうで運命になってしまったんだけどね
自分の人に殺されちゃったし
で 僕 なんで私はその人のことを頭に来るかというと
例に出てくるんですね
何もできない もう俺はもんだから一番偉くなったりたくなる
それで周りにいるのはみんなもう専門家たちだからやってくれると
それで人々はやってあげる分はうまくいくんです
ちょっとでも間違ったら全部ダメになっちゃうんで
だからそういう人を殺しちゃうし
で 結局結果としては あの
大統領 この人こそ国で現れた一番優れた人とみんな応援していたんです
どこを行っても大祭りなんです
こんな人が現れなかったと
大祭りして その人 あの
亡くなったというメッセージがラジオで流れたら
聞いた瞬間で みんなあっちこっちから店に行って爆竹ですか
買って爆竹やったんです
あれは大祭りであるもんなんです
だから結局そんな結果なの
それでこの大統領関係の人
すごく怒って なんという残酷な国民かと
怒ったってしょうがないですから
人の気持ちだから 死んでよかったと
絶対ああいう仏教の国でやらないことなんです
人が亡くなったら白い旗を立てますけど
立てなかったんです どこに
だから国家の国家葬式にやりましたけど
まあそれ関係の人々いただけで
その人々も行かなかったり行ったりとかね
かわいそうでしたけど
その間で軍隊の人がまたテロリストたちに殺されちゃったんです
その人は殺されたことに
もう過去形で白い旗を立てていたんです
だから普通の国民が亡くなったら
国民みんな過去形で白い旗と
国民には力ありますから
しょうがないんだけどね
そこはよく自分が まあ自分の身をもって知ってる話だからね
やっぱり あの でも私はその人のこの活動力
やる気っていうのは驚いたもんですよ
すごいやる気がある人でしたけどね
私はよく知ってるんです
亡くなった人を  よく喋るわ
ああだこうだ もうちょっとだってもうちょっと会ったら
もういろんなことをこれはこうで
その間に何か言ったら
もう大統領 これはこうやっていいんでしょうと
あ そうですか じゃあすぐその人に命令するちゃうんです
そこでものすごい一番偉い人
ものすごい偉い人な 僕に言ったんです
彼が大統領になったら
あの もう大統領 私はあなたの仕事ぶりを見て大変気に入ったんだと
ですから こういう仕事をあなたにやりますからね
なんかあなた 私の方でやってほしいことがあるならば言ってくださいと言ったら
その人は自分が生まれ育った田舎があって
そこすごい田舎なんですね
で あの その田舎にこの電気つけてほしいんだと
村人に それ私には何も要りませんと
はい 分かりました その場ですぐ電話取って
電気会社に あの あの なんとか村にすぐあの電線引きなさいと
大統領命令直通です そこで電気会社の方ももう考えて
これ誰のことやと見たら
この人のことって この人を個人的に呼んで
あの もう大統領はね 命令したっても
あの これの予算必要だと
それは国会から全然下りませんと
それからこの村っていうのは山の真ん中で
で どういうところから電線
高圧電線引いて それから村に普通の電線引かなくちゃいけない
これはもう もう億単位でお金
かかるんだと ですから申し訳ないんだけど
大統領に言わないでくださいと
これは実行できませんと
今のうちは そのうちはどんどん開発していくんだから
あまりお金かからないようにできてというと
我々はやりますと で その人
私の大統領っていうのはそんなもんだと
で この亡くなった人をね
亡くなった人の悪口で悪いんだけど
やっぱり僕は仏教の者だから
この心の働きのところから見るんですね
見るとものすごい行動派で
だから国の大統領までなったんだから
やる気がものすごいあるんです
やろうって何でも でももうバカだから何でもやるんでやってわかってやるわけじゃないんです
そこで結果としてはお祭り的に人間 3年間いたんだけど
国の経済状態 赤字だけでもう立て直せないほど国が倒産したし
もうすごいもう 10万単位で人が死んじゃったし
そんな結果なんです ですから
無知で心が血でっていう心が汚れたら
やる気があったっても
あまり意志が良くないんですね
危ないんですよ ですから
意志は必要なんですが
汚れた意志で行動すると結果が必ずしも悪いという仏教の立場なんです
そこでそちらの反対は
貪りの代わりに不貪 貪りがない心
いわゆるそれ説明いたします
で 私が成功するそうではなくて
この仕事を成功してあげますと
そうするとみんないいでしょうと
せっかくこの会社に雇ってもらったんだから
やっぱりその分自分が恩返ししなくちゃいけないんだと
いわゆる恩返しみたいな感じでしてあげると
そういう気持ちで頑張っちゃうと
そういう人々は成功しちゃうんですね
もう課長までいかなくたっても
その会社にとっては欠かせない人になっちゃうし
リストラにもなりませんし
自分としてもうよかったと
仕事してよかったと 退職した後でももうすごい充実感で終わっちゃうんです
ほんのちょっとの心の入れ替えなんですね
例えば子供が試験受けると
私は合格してやるぞと思ったら
貪りのエネルギーで やっぱりここまで親がね
一生懸命私のことを面倒見てくれたり
ものすごいお金も使ったし
もうお母さんもそれなりにすごい苦労してるし
お父さんもそれなりに頑張ってるし
で 先生たちも一生懸命もう教えてくれるし
私も信頼しているし やっぱり私は成功出してあげなきゃ
これはいけませんと けしからんと
みんなの希望にちゃんと応えてあげなくちゃいけないんだとという気持ちになっちゃうと
なんか自分というよさが消えちゃうんですね
なんか大きくなっちゃうんですね
先生の喜びの顔を見たいし
両親の喜びの顔を見たいし
で みんな希望通りに行ったとみんな思ってくれるし
だからなんか自分一人じゃないと
自分のために合格するんじゃないと
ただ この試験は合格しておかなくちゃいけないと
なんとなく何か自分を得ようということではなくて
恩返しするんだという気持ちになっちゃうと
と ものすごく力が入るんです
で うまくいくんです 決して悪い結果にはならない
これは不貪のエネルギーというんですね
で よく見えるのは この現代社会では
このあなたのためでしょうと
あなたのためだからやりなさいと
その気持ちでやっちゃうと
あまりやる気が出てこない場合もあるし
そこでもし私のためにやるぞと思ってやって成功したっても
その人々はどこかで失敗するんですね
なぜならば欲でやってるんだから
自我中心にやってるんだからうまくいかないんです
どこかでエネルギー出ちゃうんですね
ですから 私のためとか
なんとかのためではなくて
なんかちょっと貪りのない不貪の気持ちでやった方がいいんじゃないかなと
そこにこの清らかな気持ちなんですね
例えば私は今喋ってますけど
私がここでこの講義をちゃんとやらなくちゃということになっちゃうと
私ということで汚れちゃうんですね
そうじゃなくて 皆様一生懸命
こんな難しい理解もしにくい
ややこしい話をね もうやっぱりそれでも仏教って何なのかと知りたがってるんだと知りたがっていて
この大事な時間を使ってるんだから
必死になって教えてあげなくちゃいけないんだと
自分の力を絞ってと そういうのがむさぼりのエネルギーじゃなくて
反対の布団のエネルギーなんですね
私も今日もその気持ちで来たんだから
本当は話はしゃべりたくないほどややこしくて難しいんですね
でもこれ難しいんだからどうしようかと困るところじゃないんだと
たとえ難しくたっても
必死になって仏教って何なのかと聞きたくていらっしゃるんだから
それを答えてあげなくちゃいけないんだと
そこで自我を捨てるんですね
欲のエネルギーを捨てて
布団のエネルギーでしゃべろうとする
で 私は疲れなくしゃべれますけどね
皆様疲れますけどね で
布団 で怒りの反対は不信と言うんですね
怒りの反対のエネルギーを作ったっても
確実に合格する 確実に成功する
それは慈しみの気持ちなんですね
例えば 自分が会社ですごくよく仕事をすると
それで私は頑張っちゃうとみんな助かるでしょうと
私のためにやってるんじゃなくて
私は何か失敗したらみんなに迷惑でしょうしと
私は怠けちゃったらみんなに迷惑かけるんだと
だから怠けてはいけませんと
この仕事大事ですよと
そういう風に この他人に対する慈しみの気持ちで
で やらねばならないという気持ちが作っちゃうんです
例えばお母さんたちがもう誰よりもすごい重労働をなさってるでしょうね
家で 子供がいる時はね
小さい時は 寝る時間はないし
で その上また朝早く起きなくちゃいけないし
朝起きてのはいいんだけど
まあもし幼稚園に行ってない子供がいるんだったら昼寝もできないし
ものすごい重労働あるんだけど
全部やるでしょうね 何のこと文句もなしに
あのエネルギーはどこから出てくるんでしょうかというと
やっぱり自分が仕事をしっぽかすといけませんと
そうするとこの子供はどうなるんですかと
家庭はどうなるんですかと
やっぱり頑張らなくちゃと
そこで自分のためという気持ちが消えちゃうんですね
消えちゃったらもう元気が出てくるんです
なんで私だけ苦労しなくちゃいけないんだと思った瞬間
その人はもう不幸 もう体力がなくなっちゃう
体が壊れる そういうことなんですね
ですから それは清らかなエネルギー
我々はいつでもそれできますね
私がしゃべるところ 皆様はやっぱり仏教のことを知識
基礎的な知識を得てほしいんだと
それはもうやらなくちゃいけないと
で 皆様のことはすごく尊く思うと
そうするとうまく仕事できる
社会の中でもみんなそういうふうに社会の人々を尊いんだと
社会におかげてはいけないんだと
社会のおかげで生きているんだと
だからやらなくちゃいけないんだと
オリンピックに出る時も同じことなんですね
それは私がメダル取るんじゃないんだと
この名誉はみんな元気
元気になりますから やっぱり応えてあげなくちゃいけないんだと
という気持ちになったら
ベースに全部小さく見えちゃうんです
他のことは 自分の苦しみも
他のライバルのことも小さく見えちゃう
そうすると成功する可能性はあるんですね
ですから 怒りに汚れたらダメであって
その代わり慈しみに清らかになったら
確実にその意志は成功する
そこで無知の反対に知恵なんですね
で 何でもやるそうじゃなくて
ちゃんと理解 これだったらできそうと
こういうこういう風にすればこの仕事成功できるんだと
で そこで自信がついちゃって
じゃあやりますと なんであんたこの仕事やりたいんだ？いえ
これはもうできるんだと
やれば こういう そういう
なんとなく理解持ってること
理解を持ってると確実にそれは成功する
ですから意志は必要なんですが
もう時間も飛びました
意志は必要なんですが
その意志自体が貪瞋痴で汚れると
決していい結果にならない
不幸な結果になる 不貪不瞋
その場合も無知 智慧なんですね
智慧で清らかになると抜群に効果が得られるんです
その二種類しかないんです
で クサラチェタナとアクサラチェタナ
チェタナは二種類しかないんです
ですから 我々は幸福な人間になりたいと思うならば
この汚れた意志ではなくて
清らかな意志に入れ替えなくちゃいけないんですね
問題は私が幸福になりたいという気持ちなんで
問題は すごくこの問題になるんですね
引っ掛けになるんですね
なぜならば 私がこういうふうになりたいと言った途端
それはもう貪瞋痴で汚れている可能性あるんです
ですから 私 私 私という
その強烈な実感は 仏教ではもう置いておけと
使うなと 使う時も気をつけて使うと
この自我さえ問題なんです
自分消えれば消えるほど
自分という意識が物事をうまくいくんです
でも残念ながら人間がうまくいってほしいのは自我意識強い時なんですね
私が成功しなくちゃ 私が幸福にならなくちゃ
そう思う人々は誰一人も成功はしないんです
成功するためには ありとあらゆるからくりやら
裏でいろんな汚いことをやらなくちゃいけないんです
あんなものは成功とは言わないんです
私が成績出さなくちゃいけないと思ったらいろんな工夫するでしょうに
工夫といったっても悪い工夫
それでもう成功とは言えませんし
正しい勝負じゃないんだから
ですから この幸福になりたいと思う気持ちは
残念ながら私がという意志から生まれてくるんですね
それではダメですね だから
これ ずいぶん心理学的な立場から言うと
もうずいぶん難しいことなんです
私という意志がなくなって
行動して成功するということはね
でもできることはできるんです
私は今もうずっと喋ってることは全部自分がもう実行して試してから言ってるものなんです
一つもおとぎ話で言ってるわけじゃないんです
ですから 私もいろいろ他の人からね
まるっきりこんなことできっこはない
できっこはないと 大勢の人々に言われることをもうやったことあるんです
その時もすぐわかるのは
これ私がやってみんなにやってみせろという気持ちが出たら
それ自我でしょ そうじゃなくて
それは捨てて でもみんなで
でもこういうことできればいいでしょうと
できれば悪いわけはないんだと
じゃあいろいろもうやってみましょうと
でいて 私は自分を捨てる
自分を捨てて その仕事だけ
このやってやりたいことだけ考えちゃうんですね
私が成功するんじゃなくて
その仕事だけうまくいけば
村人にみんなにいいんだと
思っちゃうと 何のことなくすごくこのいろんなもう道が見えちゃうんですね
道が見え この場合こうして
これはこうして これはこうしてと
そこで人はびっくりするほど希望通りに 100%成功しちゃう
それで成功したってベースに
まあどうだいと 俺がやったんではないかと気持ちは出てこないんです
なぜかというと そういう気持ちでやったことでもないし
自分でやったことでもないんです
だから いろんな人の助け必要だから
そのその人々の能力を計算して
そのその仕事をちゃんと分かってあげて
うまくいけるように一応もう基本的なものをセットして置くんですね
置いたら 物事はなんとなくうまくいく
自我をどこにでも出さない
ですから 自我を出しちゃったら
私がやってやるぞと思ったらもう全くダメなんです
僕らはずっと説法しているんだから
自分の国でもやっぱり説法するときに
私はもう立派に喋ると思ったら全然喋れないんです
だからほとんど暗記して喋ってるでしょうに
だから普通とは随分違うんです
メモを書いて読むならば
もうもう読めばいいんだからね
僕らはもう訓練を受けているのは全部暗記して喋らなくちゃいけないんです
だから もし思い出せなかったらどうします？ちょっとでも神経質になっちゃって
覚えてるものを思い出せなくなりますよ
だからずっとこの俺という自分という概念を置いといて
この仏法僧の仏教のこの仕事は果たさなくちゃいけないんだと
この場合は説法しなくちゃいけないんだと
この信者さんの心に仏教の知識を与えてあげて
信仰を高めて智慧が現れるようにやるのは仕事やと
で そういうことと ちゃんともう思い出しますし
喋れるし 全然信者さんに褒めてくれたっても
全然面白くも何にもないんですね
別に自分がやったという気持ちがないんだから
それを長老たちに何か批判されるかな
それは気になりますけどね
君 あれはああいうところ
ああいう風に言ったんだけど
あれは間違ってるよと言ったら
それをすぐもう考えて
また勉強し直すとか ですから
この特に我々の仕事っていうのはなかなかできないんです
自我張っちゃうと で たまたま出家する人々がいるんですけど
このもう社会人でいてすぐ出家するとかね
うまく成功しないんです
急に自我捨てることはできません
小さい時からもうそこで叩き直してないと
あなたは何者でもないんだと
で 出家すると我々は暗記した文章がありまして
この出家する前に暗記しなくちゃいけないんです
すごい長い もうもう文章なんです
2  3ページ 小さな文字で印刷したっても 2 3
ページに行くんですね
その中に一つあったのは
この これ向こうの言葉であったんだけど
あの玄関マットのように高慢な
この人の性格ずっと言ってるので
これからあなたはこういう性格の人間にならなくちゃいけないんだと
それで一つあったのは
玄関マットのように高慢なしに
またズルズルするとまた文章が流れるんですね
だから僕はどこか昔 なんかどこかにちょっともう喧嘩しちゃったらね
ガキの頃 ある長老にすぐこのこれ言ったんです
その文だけ 叱ったわけじゃないんです
僕らは暗記している文章の玄関マットのように高慢なしにそれだけ自分一人で言った
言ったんだけど あれはチーンと心にあ
自分がやったことは行動は悪いんだと
だから性格を直す道っていうのはものすごい
もう仏教こそプロの世界だから
本当に心理学のね 絶対的に直せちゃうんですね
だからどういう意味ですかね
玄関マットというのはみんな子供から偉い人からみんな足を踏むところなんですね
だから自分が玄関マットだと
もう文句言うなと 何を何を拭いても
誰が拭いても 自分の仕事だけしなさいと
そういうことで まあだから人の汚れをね
心の汚れを落とす仕事もありまして
それは決して偉くなってやる仕事じゃないので
玄関マットの立場でやる仕事なんですね
で なんでそういう風にお釈迦様の教えの中に出てくるんですかって
これ大変な仕事なんです
仏教っていうのは 教えるっていうこと
大変なことなんです みんなに嫌われる仕事なんです
みんな欲やら怒りやら高慢それしか持ってないんだからね
この清らかな心そころと言ったっても
もうあっち行きなさいと言われるし
でも誰も言われないんです
断らないんです というのはやっぱり
そういうふうに心は育てられているんだからなんですね
今でもどんな仕事でも
まあお坊さんたちが目になってやっちゃうと
もうびっくりするほど成功するんですね
自分の国でこの学校でも教えているんだけど
お坊さんたちがね で 学校っていうのはどうしても管理できませんだけどね
大体学長とかそういう仕事を坊さんにあげません
あんた方はそんなこと知りませんだからと
お寺ばっかし育てとか
それでも仕事をしているとどんどん上々行っちゃいますから
どうしてもお坊さんたちが勉強もよくしちゃうし
たまに学校学長とかになったりするんですね
したら その学校にだけ何の問題もない
何のトラブルもない だからって普通の佐伯の学長みたいにすごい威張ってるかっていうとそうでもない
ただのお坊さんで みんなと遊んだり
いろいろなことをやったり
全くもうおじいちゃんみたいな感じなんですね
でもそれで自我がないんだから
子供たちは何のことなく言うことを聞いてくる
で 怖くないしね 全然そういうお坊さんたちのこと全然怖くない
で これも引っ張っちゃうし
で 何かしゃべりたければ
お坊さんと だからお坊さん自分であれば応えなくちゃいけないし
もう学校の格で呼んだらもう怒ってもいいんだけど
なんだいと聞かなくちゃいけないし
そうすると子供たちはいつでも話してくれる相手であって
すごくうまくいっちゃうんですね
まあそれでもまあ佐伯の人々はそういう与えてくれませんから
なかなか行きませんだけどね
やっぱり私が自分で見た限りは
やっぱり清らかな心のお坊さんなんですけど
やるとうまくいくんですということなんですね
ところが欲と言ったら
いくらお坊さんであろうとうまくいかないんです
必ずどこかで失敗しちゃう
ですから この自我なしに行動するのは大変難しいんですが
それだけ物事を成功する道なんですね
我々はどんな悪い運命で生まれても
自我さえ捨てれば そこでもう人生にはどんな問題も生まれません
子供を育てる時も 自我を置いておいて子供を育てると
会社の仕事も自我を置いておいて仕事をすると
何でもそうなんです 洗濯にしたっても
私がかっこよくみんなに見せようと思ったらかなり苦しいんです
やっぱり汚れたボロ服着ちゃったらみんなに迷惑だからと
見てる人々には良くないんだと
という気持ちでやるとやる気が出てくるんですね
そうすると丁寧に洗えるし
で そういうことでこの運命は変えられますし
変えたければすごい意志を持って頭のプログラムを変えなくちゃいけないし
その時もこれを気をつけて
悪い意志ではなくて いい意志で
不貪不瞋不痴の意志でプログラムを変えなくちゃいけないんですね
で あのー 次は何と言いますか
いろいろカルマのことをこのテーマとちょっと変わりますけど
人の実際の行動のこととカルマのことを説明いたします
一応今日はここら辺で終了したいんですが
もし質問があるならばどうぞ
[背景の雑音]